British billionaire Richard Branson has
big plans for the Colombian border town
of Kakuta he says his goal is to raise
money for food and medical supplies and
ultimately get it across the border to
Venezuela meanwhile the everyday
struggle for locals goes on many cross
the border here regularly to pick up
desperately needed supplies they're
hoping to see change soon liras we want
to be free we want to be able to cross
the border we want freedom and the
government to fall we all want and
election so we can have a new president
you post any representing some however
have lost all hope and are taking
extreme measures describing how it feels
to be leaving their country for good
this is degrading for a human being very
degrading president Nicolas Maduro is
also taking extreme measures he sees any
attempt to bring in aid as a pretext for
military intervention on Thursday he
closed the country's border with Brazil
and said he was also considering closing
the frontier with Colombia a complete
closure of the border with Colombia I'm
considering that if it's best for a man
to be prepared it's even better for a
nation to be prepared that could make
things tricky for opposition leader and
self-proclaimed president Hwang Guido he
left his home in Caracas on Thursday to
make the 800 kilometer journey to the
Colombian border he and thousands of his
supporters the promising to bring us aid
into the country but he's not yet
explained how they plan to do it
meanwhile back at the border just across
the river from cúcuta president Maduro
is organizing his own concert on
Venezuelan soil let's get more now we
are joined by DWS Jennifer Camino
Gonzalez so Jennifer tell us what does
each side hope to achieve with the
concerts on the border with Colombia
well for Richard Branson side it's about
raising funds raising awareness and
supporting this push to bring aid
through Venezuela but for Maduro it's to
counter that he wants to counter this
message he wants to say oh look I can
also stage a concert I can also bring my
people as well and and to sort of battle
would you say with public opinion as
well but we haven't received a lot of
details from the from the Maduro side
about what does concert details who's
going to be in it and so but we have
received a lot of information about the
other concert so it'll be interesting to
see both play out and just how the
government tries to compete with it with
the Richard Branson which is Richard
Branson concert which is gonna be huge
so I mean that's the situation on the
border but let's talk about what's going
on in the country itself because Maduro
z' government has been preventing aid
from entering the country
it has shut the border with Brazil as we
know talk with us a little bit more
about the current humanitarian situation
in Venezuela
well the situation is dire in particular
with with the situation of men's
shortage of medicines people don't have
medicines all of the hospitals of public
hospitals are collapsed people can't get
basic things such as syringes and many
many people say that when they have
problems and they go to the hospital
they have to bring their own medicines
and and that is quite the critical issue
in fact in san cristobol a city that is
near cúcuta a group of doctors got
together to denounce the situation and
say that they want the humanitarian aid
to come in because this it's very dire
but it's also a shortage of food it is
really really difficult for people right
now so that is the question are people
going to see Maduro closing off the the
borders to its aid and say no we want
this aid and then
that is what one way though as hoping
how much support does he have Guido
well international support he has plenty
in Venezuela of course what the
opposition is the opposition is
completely behind him and and we know
that some elements of the army some some
higher needs not so many higher ranking
officers have gone to him but some
support has broken but the needle has
really not pushed enough and and so he
he really needs to build more support he
needs to rather population but it's
difficult it's difficult because the
army is still standing behind them and
so we shall see what happens if that can
change this weekend
Jennifer Camino Gonzalez thank you
you